as an individual to see what evolution
you're you're personally going through
right like hey as you change and your
life changes and you're making money and
you have kids and you get married and
you move you might as well I used to be
interested I'm really not interested
that's not my passion that's not my
fight this is not my fight I want to
enter and then now you're going into
True Crime you know with the this this
recent one that you did which is uh uh
what's his name Steve Avery Stephen
Avery yeah and what happened with that
so out of all the topics you could have
chosen to do documentary on why this
it's actually a perfect build on
destroying the BLM narrative and it's a
perfect build on who I am and how I got
into this place we started this
conversation by talking about you know
Trump coming down and me not wanting him
to be there and then me realizing that I
was a victim of propaganda my entire
life and so as a cultural Warrior if
that's what you want to call me
um I I am really focused on getting
people to understand that their entire
life could potentially being decided
upon by Propaganda by propagandist
effort that what they think they know
they don't know